they are two of the stars of man with a
plan on CBS which anytime you see a
football game you know is America's most
watched Network and season two of it
premiered this very past Monday it's on
every Monday at 8:30 p.m. Eastern Time
good to see matt LeBlanc and Kevin
Nealon good to see you guys thank you
we've already had such a great time
we've had so many memories on the show
already with the golf thing yes you did
the golf clip of our show yes indeed
took a break for commercial now we're
back free coffee free coffee we had
before the show an excellent cup of
coffee is it really good I mean where
would you rate it in terms of talk shows
that you've been on to get where you've
received right up there right up there
the seven well I thought the service was
excellent okay yeah she one right away
or to Starbucks and got it yep and end
when it arrived rich gave it to us
and I'm so hot he didn't have someone
else give it to us he gave see I'm a man
of the people you are he handed to us as
if he went to Starbucks and got it
that's right now when I have celebrities
in my green room I'm in the man of the
people you know I mean like I really I
really get into the nitty-gritty yep and
and his green good good to have you guys
we had a great time
[Laughter]
so Matt you are from the Boston area
yes okay so that means you grew up did
you grow up in a big time Boston sports
household where everyone was talking red
sox and yeah ox and Bruins and midgets
and that's my family all roots for them
writers did good this last week yes they
did they did Tom Brady is the 40-year
old man just slinging it around against
the Denver Broncos and yeah can I just
say something yes indeed I'm from New
England mmm Connecticut right between
New York and Boston it was hard to
choose you know but why would it be an
etiquette Aventine Connecticut
they have highlight what they did yes
the Milford the Milford High lie it
makes you rethink your life's purpose
when you've been to the mill for
dialogue you know when you see people
betting their Social Security check I
some guy you know interrupts
damn who takes his cesta and turns it
over yes I like that you know the name
of the best oh I can go Piloto go
cranberry bog and with me exactly yeah
but um I think I just don't like the
Patriots because of Tom Brady he's just
too good look and he's got the hot wife
he's so talented and I'm just jealous I
think so I kind of root for them to lose
all right
tell your family I'm sorry just like I
root for him to lose this have to be
bitter that bitter it's not hate why not
only guy with a hot wife why not well
yeah your wife is good-looking but
that's hot before now she's good-looking
she's hot just you dominated or like
within a minute I know that defeat you I
don't want you to get upset with me
you're a lot bigger than I think I think
Tom Brady's entitled to have a
good-looking wife your wife is hotter
well then don't play football have one
or the other am i right rich well I mean
there is such a thing as being greedy
yeah five Super Bowl that's you your
wife is hot you're very funny guy
successful career you have a lot of
money talented talented I think Matt's
telling you I think what he's telling
you is that you're the Tom Brady of
comedy Kevin there you go there you go
all right well that we're here you are
here you are with a hot wife man with a
plan yeah may not let many credits in
you're a lot of credit in your credit a
lot of units whatever they might call it
I am DB Paige you're the Tom Brady
you've come you know what people see me
sometimes they'll say hey you're from
you're from Saturday at like I said no
I'm from Connecticut originally they do
that for you from friends they don't ask
you from Saturday well oh no I've never
been on that show are you serious
everyone everyone you had have been
asked I mean in the must-see TV we do a
friends every I was the only one that
didn't host it I was he's proud of us so
I was afraid so in other words for the
three of us here you're saying you you
get Center Night Live all the time you
get friends even though why can't we
he's done you get weeds to I get a lot
of stuff he just gets friends
so he gets great weeds which is by the
way right here on the audience channel
as well I get SportsCenter all the time
even though I haven't been on it for 14
years I know I get people who would just
hum the sports it's hard when you peek
early is peeking early reference or
you're just referencing back to
conversation he's also talked about his
wife was hoping to get lucky today yeah
I'm sorry you're talking about your wife
my wife isn't an episode of Friends it
was the one it was in the coffee shop
and okay just a small the one where we
were in the coffee house coffee shop
there might have been something going on
between two people this is all about me
today by the way yeah Kevin you when I
first Hollywood I saw taping of a sitcom
called bosom buddies but Tom Hanks the
shore Scolari and they play women in
there and I and I didn't know the whole
thing was about them dressed on a big
woman and so every time I saw it on TV I
go oh that's that must be the episode I
saw when they tape it because it's just
like women come off and somebody finally
told you it was I finally realized ways
that way yeah yeah where you did
somebody let you down gently no I
figured out myself very good yeah tell
anybody
Kevin Nealon and Matt LeBlanc here on
the Rich Eisen show how is your golf
game Kevin how's that going it's not
good why not not because I'm not
talented right it just it's a sport that
takes a lot of practice uh-huh and a lot
of commitment mm-hmm but I think I could
be really really good if I had like the
leisure time that most of those
professional golfers exactly if you
could spend every single day on your
craft being golf yeah I'm trying to get
mad at the golf have you Matt have you
played ever
I played nine holes one time at what's
it broke a window in the parking lot at
Jerry's deli
no no no and when you get to the corner
I think I hit it you supposed to go that
way and I went and went wrong so here
you are it hasn't been throwing his club
though yeah that's true so seriously
your your golf experience here in the
los angeles area is to go to a municipal
course based on two wits it went to
Whitsitt where you know I take my kids
sometimes on the driving we're cheap
it's very not to spend money on
something I know I'm gonna stink so
somebody somebody sitting there having a
corned beef on rye carries the ball
officer the Titleist hit by Matt LeBlanc
comes in the window well when that when
it came through the window was not hit
by you know Matt LeBlanc was hit by that
yeah be he brought an accent accent yeah
I used to used to park the car and come
on get it go outside does it come back
it wicked awesome when I go home yeah
when I go home and hang out with my
friends from high school right it gets
it gets pretty thick
so what is your sport if you pegged your
sport that you you spectate or you paid
in or what would that be misses well I
guess when I was a kid the first team I
played on I played baseball and then got
into football which I really liked when
you playing football I played middle
linebacker then I played outside
linebacker then I played defensive end
okay people basically yeah never once
and I touched the ball ah that's not
true okay that's what you one time to my
highlight of Pop Warner football
defensive end well you just when you
started talking about real this is a
good moment check this out so well got
around the got around the the offensive
lineman real quick he stumbled getting
up off the line and I got around the
outside and I looked and I see the
full-back tracking out to the right and
I look in the quarterback lateral some
of the ball and I was right there it
caught it and took off and ran for a
touchdown six six yeah and I'm not very
fast so thank God it was only like 30
yards cuz they'd look behind me boy they
were catching me so fast
do you have any sort of glorious moments
like that from your never plenty I get
playing you know I was a I was a
quarterback in college mmm I think we
talked about this one time fair flee
University and kicker and punter and
rich I was gonna trap for the USFL yes
for the Los Angeles I think was the LA
Express at the time hmm
you think I'm kidding but it's true by
the way I'm right on the edge of
wondering if you're I bought like six
USFL footballs which were a little bit
lighter than the NFL footballs and I
would go to Fairfax High and practice my
kicking and I was gonna be a free agent
walk on and try out as a kicker punter
and kicker
so what happened well this is gonna be
my like my hook from my stand-up comedy
oh he does stand-up but he's also the
kicker for the LA but my career
thankfully took off before I had to go
for tryouts so comedy got in the way of
your kick it did but I still have those
footballs in my closet the garage do you
really you didn't try out I didn't end
up trying up it was a delete get
canceled before your tryout
questioned the league but um I've been
on many shows that got canceled yeah
Kevin Nealon and uh matt LeBlanc here on
the Rich Eisen showed you have scores of
Kevin eelain's last appearance at the
yes a Tahoe classic yeah the American
Century championship up in Lake Tahoe so
you know Marty Marc mold or one again
yes Marty fish came in second tennis
player extraordinaire Charles Barkley
came in last actually Kevin Nealon
finished just ahead of Charles Woodson
Al Michaels Oh Jared Goff and Derek
Fisher nice so they're all looking up at
Kevin Nealon these are professional
athletes by the way God beat Jared golf
might wind up being MVP of the NFL if he
continues on with what he's doing right
now yeah guys good you play with Jared
Goff I was splitting the tournament with
him but okay I gather but I played with
Barkley all the time you know how cuz we
both are pitiful he's terrible terrible
terrible as he says I'm gonna tell you
know I want I don't go to many
professional football games yeah I took
my son to see the Rams play when oh this
is like
Wester okay yeah and I was just amazed
at how little action there is in a
football game they're always standing
around on the field for commercials or
whatever is how much actual time are
they running on well if you yes they if
you must know because it's the the
secret of the National Football League
if you actually ran a stopwatch on the
actual play from snap to end of play
around ten minutes in there and 1215
minutes and the rest of it is just
sitting around and watching that kitchen
away but I could play it gives me plenty
of time to rest in between plays right
this guy could play well we you ever get
hit by a guy that weighs like 260 280
with a helmet on running at your full
speed
yeah you could play one play it's like
it and when he hits you you never man
with a plan on CBS on Monday night
season 2 just hit episodes and Top Gear
also for you Matt where do you find time
to do all this stuff
well episodes we just just finished our
final season we did five seasons of that
that was a really awesome experience
that was David Crane and Jeffrey klarik
who wrote friends so that's that was
fantastic writing and we've got a lot of
nominations for that yes indeed for four
Golden Globes force for Emmys you've
been nominated seven times for Emmy
Awards yeah that was that was a really
really fun show and it was kind of a fun
looking like behind the curtain in
Hollywood does he like all the crazy
personalities and they ramped up a few
of them and s filmed in England was fun
we shot all the interiors in the UK and
about two weeks of exteriors here but
that's over now and sadly but Top Gear
is still going on I go back and forth
you know a sitcom schedule you do three
weeks on one week off to keep the
writers a chance to stay ahead of
production so in that week off when
Kevin's relaxed and playing golf I'm
driving a car in Morocco in the desert
maniac he's just I don't think he's ever
not stopped working except for right now
yeah I'm working my nose work is that
right next to you trying
but you're a deer head correct yeah
totally you have a Ducati this guy will
talk your head off
now that was that was not code for
anything right a Ducati's Italian motors
okay I multiply crowd that's their
touring version so much about
motorcycles and cars from being on the
show and I've never seen a guy
glazed-over faster cause you just see
this sleeping with his eyes or like a
total sleep - yeah harris-san sports
Matt LeBlanc and Kevin Nealon check him
out on man with a plan on CBS every
single Monday night at 8:30 p.m. Eastern
Time
thanks for coming back Kevin thank you
please come back Matt LeBlanc I would
love to really thank you thanks for
thanks for coming hearing you got it
Matt LeBlanc and Kevin Nealon check it
all out on CBS man with a plan we are
back with your calls in a moment the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience